you get mixed emotions when you're out
there hunting the lionfish
a feeling of accomplishment because
you're actually making a difference a
feeling of competitiveness because the
fact that in my case i'm trying to be
florida's lionfish
king lionfish are a
non-native species to the atlantic the
gulf and the caribbean
because they reproduce at such a high
rate and have zero predators they are
currently taking over
the waters here
lionfish eat basically everything that
we eat which includes crabs lobsters
grouper flounder anything you name it
they're game
the scary part is is that we don't know
how many of them are out there and it's
probably a lot bigger than we ever will
know because of the fact that we always
dive the public spots or the private
fishermen spots but i mean the ocean is
huge
the lionfish challenge is a contest set
up for those of us that are making a
difference to go out and kill as many
lionfish as we can over the next four
months
not every person is a big fan of spear
fishing but the problem that we have
with the lionfish these things need to
be eliminated every one of them and
whether you're a big fan of it or not
this is just not about spear fishing
it's about taking care of our ecosystem
and making sure that everything stays
balanced
being crowned the lionfish king would
will be a huge accomplishment but
it's not just about that
the next weekend i'll probably go out
and do the same thing again even though
the competition is over
you